[Musique]
bonjour
j'aurais pu faire ce tôle que sans aide
mais à mon âge je pouvais pas donc
excusez-moi je garde les lunettes et mon
papier voilà
quand vous visitez une ville vous
recherchez d'abord ce qui fait le
patrimoine n'est-ce pas
c'est bien
que se patrimoine soit religieux ou
laïque n'est-ce pas
bien moi je recherche aussi le
patrimoine y compris le patrimoine
religieux les cathédrales les églises ou
les lieux de culte locaux
je vais donc vous raconter l'histoire
des fesses de l'église de lèche donc
l'académicien andré Frossard dira plus
tard mais c'est une petite Sixtine il a
non seulement dit mais j'ai une lettre
qui le prouve
nos cerveaux aiment la couleur tous les
scientifiques le disent c'est pour ça
que mes fresques sont très colorés mais
vous verrez elles ne sont pas criardes
très tôt peindre et dessiner était pour
moi une évidence toute petite autre
comme trois pommes je barbouillais déjà
les murs chez ma grand-mère qui
m'élevait
et j'adorais accompagner ma soeur aînée
à la messe
et là dans l'église il y avait une
peinture au-dessus de l'hôtel
mais alors qui n'était pas mon goût du
tout du tout et je me disais quelqu'un a
eu un jour la chance de pouvoir faire
quelque chose pour le bon Dieu dans une
église et il a fait ça
si moi je pouvais faire quelque chose
pour le bon Dieu dans une église je
ferai tout du mieux que je peux j'y
mettrai tout mon coeur
des années plus tard on est venu habiter
à lèche un village en Seine-et-Marne
et là l'église était perpétuellement
fermé
et pour cause un bloc de voûte c'était
effondré en enfonçant le sol
et en laissant large espace béant vers
le ciel à cette époque il y a plus de 35
ans l'église était déjà en restauration
à cette époque je revenais d’égypte et
là
j'avais été frappé par la beauté la
splendeur des monuments
et je me disais les gens qui avaient
fait ces constructions dont on peut
encore admirer les vestiges aujourd'hui
devait avoir une foi immense pour
construire ses temples
et pourquoi et bien parce qu'ils avaient
leur foi leur religion de graver dans
les pierres et ils nous ont laissé
leur civilisation
ancrées dans nos mémoires pour
l'éternité
je relevé un exemple sur le temple de
combo je relevais le phare à ONG que
vous pouvez voir ici parce qu'il
concrétisaient vraiment les codes de la
régicien il avait bien la tête de profil
un oeil de face les épaules de face et
les deux pieds de profil je ne savais
pas quand je l'ai dessiné qu'il me
servirait un jour pour les fresques pour
les dix plaies d'Égypte
il manque toujours quelque chose des
lieux consacrés des lieux religieux et
je faisais taire les touristes dans ce
dans ce temple même si plus personne
maintenant ne croit au dieu crocodile
je les faisais taire
et l'église de mon village restait
toujours Claude mais un jour en rentrant
de course je vois la porte ouverte
j'arrête la voiture je vais voir et à
l'entrée monsieur ragonet que vous voyez
là
me dit
c'est interdit c'est dangereux
mais restez bien sur la gauche je rentre
je regarde
tout est sale et délabré dans un état
lamentable mais là en moins d'une minute
j'ai su que j'allais faire quelque chose
je ne savais pas quoi mais quelque chose
que c'était possible que je le pouvais
que je le devais
je rentre à la maison
et je commence à réfléchir
il ne me revient à l'idée que les
histoires de Thérèse Bernadette Louis de
mariage
ou de Saint-Nicolas mais ce n'est pas ça
la religion il faut revenir au
fondamentaux à la Bible
j'en ai parlé au maire de l'époque
Monsieur Nizar et il m'a donné
l'autorisation verbale de pouvoir faire
des fresques dans l'église et j'ai
travaillé avec un chargement
et j'ai présenté les dessins et ils
m'ont dit d'accord on vous donne les
clés allez-y le résultat
[Applaudissements]
n'ayant pas à faire à des critiques
d'art moderne ou contemporains
entièrement libre et autonome j'ai pu
concevoir cet ensemble entièrement
adapté hostile et à l'architecture du
bâtiment il me fallait beaucoup de
motivation en voici deux
il n'y a pas de beaucoup de femmes dont
le nom est cité dans la Bible toutes
celles qui sont cités sont sur les
fresques
et il me fallait une motivation
religieuse
définir que pour les chrétiens Jésus
était bien le Messie annoncé par les
écritures
je retourne sur place je prends les
mesures et je réfléchis à la composition
celle-ci sera basée sur un axe vous
pouvez vous en rendre compte là cet axe
sera
partira de la porte d'entrée jusqu'au
dessus de l'hôtel
voilà alors voilà la composition
en trois parties la partie A
là et raconté l'histoire du peuple élu
et celui que les fresques se lisent
comme le texte hébreu de droite vers la
gauche
en C ce sont les évangiles sur les murs
verticaux
et en B sur la sur la droite
la une petite chapelle consacrée à la
Vierge Marie
voilà là ça vous avez la partie
de l'ancien testament là c'est le
Nouveau Testament alors vous voyez
les dessins est-ce que ça donne en
couleur
ça ce sont les si la partie qui concerne
les évangiles
au-dessus
la vision préliminaire de l'Apocalypse
de Jean
et ce qui est en bleu correspond aux
armes qui attendent d'être qui sont en
purgatoire qui attendent d'être jugés
voilà la petite chapelle sur la droite
vous la voyez en bleu dans le bleu
encore une vue
sur la voûte sur le plafond sur la voûte
ce sont les ce qui est vraiment de
tradition catholique qui n'est pas
vraiment dans les livres originaux les
dessins jaillissaient sur les murs et je
commençais la mise en couleur
mais il me fallait des modèles il me
fallait des vrais personnes pourquoi
d'abord
pour les impliquer impliquer les gens du
village dans le travail que je faisais
ensuite pour montrer que ces personnes
que les gens qui vivaient dans ces temps
reculé étaient des êtres humains
exactement comme nous
et ensuite parce que comme le disait
Platon
il faut l'avoir il était dans l'unité et
l'unité dans la variété
je choisissais les modèles selon un
véritable petit casting et j'ai eu la
chance que tous les gens à qui je
proposais de poser ont accepté et
vous-même auriez-vous accepté de poser
pour moi de monter sur l'échafaudage
passer des heures comme ça pour vous
faire croître portraituré et quelle
personnage auriez-vous aimé représenter
oui
voici quelques personnes qui s'étaient
présentées et que j'avais sollicité
voilà des exemples de personnes qui ont
posé par exemple madame Roblet a plus de
85 ans elle était montée sur un petit
échafaudage qui est composé de quatre
planches sa fille la tirée par les
épaules sa fille lui poussait les fesses
et moi je tenais l'échelle en bas
c'est dommage qu'à l'époque on ne
faisait pas des photos comme aussi
facilement que maintenant
et oui miraculeux
impossible à imaginer
cette jeune fille qui est venue
représenter Marie dans une église
catholique était protestante
elle est toujours d'ailleurs
encore mieux c'est un at monsieur rameau
qui est accepté de venir poser pour
représenter Dieu
un portrait par jour de la création
voilà des gens mobilisés par le
patrimoine il y en avait beaucoup
mais pas seulement pour faire les
modèles
parce que pour pouvoir commencer à
peindre sur et dessiner sur place comme
ça il fallait que les murs soient
sa propre et sain
ils étaient très endommagés
heureusement j'ai pu compter sur le
plâtrier monsieur dos Reis qui est venu
travailler bénévolement avec du matériel
prêté par son patron et il a refait tous
les plâtres qui étaient défectueux
j'ai pu aussi compter vous voyez l'état
des murs ça c'est dans la petite
chapelle il a tout descendu le plafond
et il a tout refait
et j'ai pu compter sur mon fils
Christian
qui
a utilisé toute sa force son énergie son
enthousiasme c'est lui qui a tout gratté
poncer et enduit les murs
sans lui sans monsieur doser rien
n'aurait été possible
et chaque fois qu'il y a eu des
embêtements
des crises des empêchements
tous les toutes les horreurs que vous
pouvez imaginer et bien
des aides providentielles sont survenus
quand j'étais vraiment désespéré parce
qu'on m'avait repris les échafaudages et
que je ne vais plus rien pour travailler
j'ai pu lancer un appel au secours sur
le sur RTL
à l'émission et pour vous qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire
et Monsieur du domaine que vous voyez là
en saint Mathieu sur le vitrail
il était ailleurs de pierre et
après la guerre il avait pu restaurer
des cathédrales donc il a pu nous prêter
tous les échafaudages dont on avait
besoin et Monsieur Baudot grâce à cette
émission nous a prêté son camion pour
les transporter
et mieux encore
monsieur voilà Monsieur deck lui a
piloté l'installation des échafaudages
au centre vous voyez c'est Monsieur
doser à droite le fils de monsieur
lecarte champêtre et à gauche c'est mon
fils Christian
et mieux encore
sur ce vitrail il y a Monsieur
qui est menuisier qui est là présent
dans la salle n'est-ce pas monsieur
maxin vous êtes là oh pardon
[Rires]
[Musique]
merci
et c'est lui monsieur maxin qui a
entièrement
restauré et rénover toutes les boiseries
de l'église et voulez-vous vous voyez là
sur la photo c'est tout surtout de le
pourtour il a tout démonté restauré
refait remise à neuf et ça a duré des
mois et des mois et des mois
il ne pouvait venir que le week-end
[Rires]
là ce sont des photos des derniers
travaux qui ont été entrepris la
restauration les dernières restaurations
de l'église qui se sont terminées ce
mois-ci la remise de chantier a été le
15 mai
et au cours de cette restauration
nous avons placé dans le clocher une
capsule
spatio-temporelle dans laquelle il y a
des clés USB des documents pour les
générations futures
et c'est là que j'ai compris
que cette église de lèche était devenue
tout entière une capsule de mémoire
mémoire de ces pierres qui datent du 12e
siècle
mémoire de la Bible avec mes fresques la
Bible qui est la base de notre
civilisation
judéo-chrétienne européenne et
occidentales
et maintenant désormais mémoire du
village avec sa capsule
spatio-temporelle
ce qui nous fait visiter les monuments
religieux même si ce ne s'est pas ceux
de notre croyance c'est justement cette
mémoire cette mémoire des religions
cette religion qui fait que les peuples
sont différents et créent des cultures
et des civilisations différentes
quand nous allons visiter le Parthénon
c'est la mémoire de l'Iliade et
l'Odyssée
quand nous allons visiter des temps
plein doux c'est la mémoire de tous les
livres sacrés et anciens de ces peuples
si un jour vous voulez voir l'église la
porte est ouverte merci
[Applaudissements]